I'm feeling great to be back here in st.
Louis the US Championship is my favorite
events by far you play consistently
strong opposition there there's no free
games it's always a challenge right from
day one this is my fields championship
it is my first visit to some blues as
well and so far I like it everyone is a
grandmaster here and everyone's most
people who are playing here have beaten
me before so it's going to be a very
tough to my approach to chaz's cliche as
it sounds is just to play as many good
games as possible I've tried setting
goals before and it all it does is
pretty much sort of constrict my plants
couldn't be probably one of the last
chances for me to win so I guess my goal
is to win coming into this tournament
you're always thinking gains preparation
openings medal game tactics you want
everything to be solid but i'm still
trying to be realistic and just get it
one game at a time my emphasis in the
game is to learn and improve it's
interesting to challenge yourself and
play stronger opponents and that's
definitely something you find in the US
Championship
I think it's maybe just the feeling of
being back in st. Louis again it's just
a really really pleasant feeling the
weather is great it's so you can really
feel that it's summer here it's not like
that in New York well officer I'm really
trying to win the tournament I've come
close many times I think my this might
be there I actually win the tournament
each year I computing the championships
it's becoming harder and harder to
prepare I just finished with my law
school exams two days before arriving
for the championship course I will try
to win but I have to be realistic I
didn't play like a nurse or astronomy
since last year's championship I has a
break from chess so I will do my best to
do what I can think is that this is just
one game I play with them so so it
doesn't matter they might be better
objectively it's how how we played the
one single game so i want to put all my
efforts to do just the best i I can't I
really like it because it's really fun
playing against new people and I get to
make new friends my goal this year is to
play fighting chest and not have a
single regret with any game that I play
my dad said he said to play well so
that's what I'm gonna try to do it not
just to get lucky but to try to make
some good move